I definitely view myself as as a
franchise quarterback you know I think
as as you look at you know the other
questions and is it New Orleans is it
somewhere else like that as you go into
free agency this is the time that you
start to find out how people view you
and you know we haven't gotten into
fragrancy long enough to really know how
how these guys do me and and we'll just
handle that as it comes it's a little
taste some hill from Super Bowl week
with Rob Motty of The Associated Press
he'll made the rounds the mere fact that
he was available to talk to reporters
tells you he's thinking about his next
play whether it is in New Orleans or
somewhere else and Peter we discussed
this yesterday your comments with a
conversation rather with Sean Payton and
Peyton's thoughts on what may happen
with Taysom Hill if and when a
restricted free agency tender is applied
what a team give up a first-round pick
or at least be willing to give up a
first-round pick to son who an offer
sheet with the Saints match it look
embedded in all this is the great
unknown will Taysom Hill
be an effective quarterback if if and
when he's playing on a full-time basis
well he sure as hell sounds like a guy
who believes that he can be a franchise
quarterback and Sean Payton's compared
him to Steve Young in the past and the
Saints view him as a successor to Drew
Brees I you know look I I'm betting on
the the over here that Hill is gonna be
a great quarterback when he gets the
chance I understand it's a limited
sample size but what we've seen from him
from time to time Peter when he's on the
field and they're using him he's a man
among boys yeah I mean this is this
really complicates this free agency
season Mike because there just simply
isn't a lot of a lot of proverbial
coaches tape on Taysom Hill
and you know when I look at that play
that we're showing on the screen right
now obviously it's fantastic but I also
once saw Tim Tebow throw a touchdown
pass to beat the Dick LeBeau Steelers
and Troy Polamalu in overtime in the
playoffs and again I'm not comparing
them
I think Taysom Hill is a significantly
better quarterback passer of a football
then Tim Tebow was but having said that
there still isn't a lot to know about
Taysom Hill the quarterback
Taysom Hill the gadget player you know
he's one of the best in NFL history and
clearly in the top five who've ever
played the game as far as being a gadget
player but now you have to ask yourself
is somebody this offseason going to make
such an offer for him that the Saints
won't match and give them a chance to be
their quarterback and look there's all
sorts of weird you know rumors and and
an unfounded crapola out on the internet
right now and out in the world right now
oh the Patriots are gonna sign them oh
the Ravens are gonna sign them or
whoever but I think the key thing is if
I'm taste some Hill I'd rather go back
to New Orleans for one year and take my
chances in a quieter market in 2020
unless some team says you've got more
than a 50/50 chance to win our starting
quarterback job I mean the only the only
exception for that the only one is if
Bill Belichick sign me to a three-year
offer sheet and said you're gonna have
every chance to win the job are you
gonna win it I make no guarantees if
you're the best guy you'll play that
would be tempting if I were taste some
he'll first of all I just have to say
this I am NOT a fan of unfounded crapola
I want my crapola to be very well
founded and firmly rooted that's how I
take my crap it didn't sound very good
he says so
here's the thing about Taysom Hill I
agree with you it's a crowded house this
time around if there's a way you can
bump it to 2021 now you got to worry
about the franchise tag if you stay one
more year in New Orleans but hey there's
worse things that could happen to a guy
then being franchise tag I think that
that Sean Payton gives him the best
chance to reach his ceiling whatever it
may be and when Sean Payton compares the
guy to Steve Young and Sean Payton does
not have a reputation for engaging in
gratuitous unfounded crapola hyperbole I
take notice when he said that in August
Peter that got my attention that if they
they have a vision that this guy can be
a Steve Young are you kidding me yeah I
want to see what he can do and with Sean
Payton he's going to do more than he can
do with anyone else here's the thing
about playing for Sean Payton okay
especially if Drew Brees isn't there and
and let's say Teddy Bridgewater is and
they go with Teddy Bridgewater and and
and Taysom Hill the thing is that Sean
Payton is going to play Taysom Hill more
and more in his offense in 2020 whether
it's Bridgewater whether it's Brees
whoever because Sean Payton needs to
know the answer to these questions Mike
go back and look at his preseason game
against the Chargers last year when
Taysom Hill played a lot of that game
and he was excellent and after that game
he had some people with the Chargers
saying this guy is a real starter in the
NFL
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports